well we all started saying lies we all
lie don't we when it comes to this stuff
we do we started saying things like
mommy's job's just as important as
daddy's job it's all bollocks we all
know his bollocks would you have a male
nanny no
I'm serious no
correct I don't trust I I seriously
don't trust any man who wants to be
around young children like that well
like a teacher now it's a different
thing being a teacher well because
there's more of them available yeah
exactly so you've got your pick yeah
now I just don't trust Manny's
I don't trust them I don't either man
it's not no teach it's different because
you want to educate you want to blah
blah blah being a Manny picking them up
it's not a [__] man's job
his job is it can woman shop Mike
well you'll now canceled
if you had the money to afford a nanny
would you get a money no
no
get [__]
absolutely nothing why not
why not yeah because it's a [__]
woman's job that's why
no look
how can I say this in the way that it's
political I mean I mean we've already
gone over the line but we were joking
obviously
yeah we were joking yeah we were we were
joking and we said it's a woman's job we
were
joking no but seriously yeah it is a
task to which women are better suited
caring after young children yeah it's
just a fact of life yeah right I'm not
saying they should be doing that
although obviously they should but I
wouldn't say that in public on a live
stream yeah right not saying that that
is what they should be doing am I no are
you saying that no no neither of us are
saying that is what women should be
doing yeah women should be free to do
whatever they want and if they want to
go out to work and and earn a living I
mean we obviously disapprove of that but
they're allowed to yeah right we can't
ban them anymore unfortunately you can't
you can't which is why Society has gone
downhill a lot yeah an optimization of
society man look sexual Revolution
Louise Perry she talks about this right
yeah yeah this is what Louise always
bangs on about right the sexual
Revolution ruined everything and women
got out of the kitchen and it's been a
big problem ever since I think that's a
main point is it's our main point yeah
you know she said Louise has said many
times that she'd love to be back in the
kitchen does she yeah she said it mate
really said it in the interview did she
I missed that part yeah she did mate
yeah all right well anyway you found
that was the title of the episode
I want to be back in the kids let me get
back in the kitchen
but anyway I don't trust a man who wants
to be around young children like yeah
exactly yeah and also women are just
more natural naturally better at it yeah
you know yeah that cleaning cooking all
that sort of thing yeah all that stuff
you know it comes naturally to you Birds
Christy says does it hurt my cause that
I'm making homemade bread right now do
you know what I actually bake bread at
home as well so I'm not against doing
some women's job because you've got to
help them out yeah you've got to
otherwise they start banging on and once
they start doing that there's no [__]
stopping them you know what I mean
it's just all of that mate it just
[__] keeps going do you wonder guys
why we have to put all this banter
behind the paywall eventually because
you shouldn't haven't seen that segment
and it was obviously just us joking
Kathy kidson says you are bad
what do you mean we're bad we're just
we're just look it's not these are just
observations Kathy based on real world
facts you meant humor yeah sarcasm is
humor yeah sarcasm irony and humor
look here's Mrs works yeah right in the
wrong job exactly he's in some
Progressive [__] oh yeah yeah exactly
always who just [__] complaining
about it my missus used to work until
you know I got pregnant now finally
we've sorted her out yeah exactly yeah
and now she's done what she should be
exactly
I put up with it for years yeah for
years you know right I'm a modern man
you know I tolerated it
all started saying lies we all lie don't
we when it comes to this stuff we do we
start saying things like mommy's job's
just an important as daddy's job it's
all bollocks we all know his bollocks
okay he says you put up with it
huh
remote control account says don't be
pure all about it it's not funny be
adults about it
I'm being an adult about it exactly I
provide her with the opportunity to be
what you should be exactly exactly she
loves all that mate thank God she
doesn't matter
oh Christy says I think this is great
too funny this is why I come to your
channel there you go you've got
internalized misogyny you love this
facts being spitted